tonight the family of eric echevarrio
held a vigil to honor his life
after he was killed in a car crash on
wednesday eight news now reporter
madison kimbrough joins us live from the
memorial site near blue diamond in fort
apache
with more madison
yes tonight was about honoring eric's
life many
still not believing that he's actually
gone but the family
wants justice you know if you're going
to drink or
get high whatever you're going to do do
it in your house like don't drive he
took a
a dad from my 14 year old son he took my
husband my
my best friend my life partner my my
everything i don't even know what i'm
going to do without them
a visual was held tonight for 52 year
eric echeverria
who died last week after being hit by a
teen driver
that teen 19-year-old zeon collins is
being accused of driving under the
influence
and is facing several other charges my
family is hurting
they're in pain they feel that justice
hasn't been served
and i know it's too soon to speak but
we're hoping that
something does happen tonight friends
and family came out to honor eric's life
flowers balloons and pictures were all
set up along with music playing in the
background
family members and friends spoke briefly
before participating in a two-minute
moment of silence
you know it has taken a little bit for
it to sink in you know i'm still in
denial still in shock that
that he's gone so we're just setting
everything up making the arrangements
for
you know for our service echeveria was
described as a happy man
always smiling joking around with a
heart of gold
he was originally from new york but
spent the last 23 years here in las
vegas
he was an army vet and worked as a
custodian for the clark county school
district
for 18 years
and this is a look at his memorial site
right off of apache road
as for collins he was released with
electronic monitoring and is due in
court for a status check
on thursday january 7. reporting live
madison kimbrough
8 news now